if you've ever said Christmas has gotten
to commercial well you're not the first
complaints about excessive spending
during the holidays go back over a
hundred years when Victorians lamented
about having to buy cards and gifts for
all their acquaintances and recoiled
from the garishness of london's
department store displays today we're so
used to the marriage of Christmas
shopping that we rarely stop to wonder
how it got this way
is there something inherent about the
holiday that makes it so expensive and
is it really good for us or the economy
[Music]
many people think the tradition of
gift-giving comes from the story of the
Magi in the New Testament who visited
baby Jesus with gifts of gold
frankincense and myrrh but swapping
handmade gifts was already a part of
pagan winter festivals like the Roman
Saturnalia a raucous week-long party
which took place in late December as
Christianity spread across Europe
keeping the schedules and traditions of
established holidays made it more
attractive to prospective converts so
sometime around 300 AD the church
officially moved Jesus's birthday to
December 25th for over a thousand years
Christmas ambled along as a minor
observance nowhere near as important as
the major Christian holiday Easter in
the 1600s Puritans like Oliver Cromwell
and the pilgrims who settled America
outright banned the celebration of
Christmas because they found it too
decadent and pagan II it really wasn't
until the early 1800s that Christmas as
we know it today
started to take shape thanks largely to
authors like Charles Dickens Washington
Irving and Clement Clarke Moore who
assembled some of their favorite holiday
customs into a standardized package they
rebranded it as a family centric
celebration with a strong emphasis on
generosity that meant sharing meals
donating to charity and of course
gift giving gifts were still mostly
handmade
a lot of money was spent on boots
whether you were a poulterer
a baker a brewer or a food were it's a
word December was a busy and profitable
month as the Industrial Revolution
kicked into high gear urban populations
increased and manufactured goods became
widely available to a burgeoning middle
class gifts shifted from something you
made to something you bought by the end
of the 1800s Christmas had been
commandeered by an institution that
would hold it hostage for a hundred
years as a department store these
all-in-one mega retailers would go all
out with elaborate decorations and
window displays that attracted huge
crowds print catalogs offered an easy
way to make wish lists and in 1890 an
American businessman named James Edgar
had a crazy idea of dressing up as Santa
Claus at his Massachusetts department
store and boy did that catch up there
everyone knows Christmastime it seems to
start earlier every year but you might
be surprised to learn that the first
people to advocate early shopping were
not retailers but labor activists the
season had become so busy that the
government allowed businesses to ignore
labor laws during the month of December
and employees were routinely overworked
many of them children in her essay the
travesty of Christmas n-double a-c-p
co-founder Florence Kelly advocated
early shopping as a way to alleviate the
pressure on workers and recounts the
story of a boy who died of exposure
after working an 18-hour shift
delivering Christmas gifts New York's
freezing winter department stores were
happy to make the holiday season as long
as possible but they had a sort of
unwritten rule amongst them that they
wouldn't start promoting Christmas until
after Thanksgiving so FDR pushed the
official date of Thanksgiving from the
last Thursday in November to the fourth
Thursday in November in order to squeeze
as many days as possible into the
shopping season
in the early 50s the day after
Thanksgiving became known as Black
Friday as a reference to the general
chaos that resulted from workers calling
in sick to get a four-day weekend
by the 1960s police departments had
adopted the usage to describe the
overwhelming crowds and traffic caused
by the onset of holiday shopping
retailers embraced the name with Black
Friday sales and promotions though they
did attempt to rebrand the origins of
the term into something more positive
despite what you've heard Black Friday
is not a reference to the day businesses
give back in the black stores have been
steadily pushing back the opening time
on Black Friday in the last few decades
from dawn to midnight even to
Thanksgiving evening prompting some
strikes by workers robbed at their
holiday dinner with family today Black
Friday is something of a controversy
with viral videos of mobs pushing and
fighting each other for the best
bargains it's become a symbol of the
greed and competitiveness that Christmas
is not supposed to be about tragically
epitomized by the death of a Long Island
Walmart employee who was trampled by 200
frenzied shoppers who broke through the
glass doors before the store opened both
Oliver Cromwell and Florence Kelly would
be very disappointed if they were alive
today and they'd be very confused by the
newest form of holiday consumerism
online Christmas shopping while
ecommerce only represents around 17% of
holiday shopping that number has been
steadily growing over the past decade
particularly focus on a day that the
National Retail Federation dubbed Cyber
Monday that's right
three days after Black Friday after a
tiring weekend of mall walking it seems
that many people decide to finish up
their holiday shopping on the web and
more than half of these orders are
placed from work computers only on lunch
breaks right guys even if you find all
this commercialism distasteful you still
have to admit that this annual spending
spree is good for the economy right
maybe not while many retailers indeed
depend on Christmas to remain profitable
there are concerns that have
nothing to do with spirituality or
tradition economics professor Joel Wald
Fogle famously called Christmas a
deadweight loss which basically means
that it's a lot of spending without an
equivalent positive game for instance if
I give Philip a $10 bill I've lost 10
bucks but he's gained 10 bucks
so the overall economy has broken even
but if I give Giulia a $10 gift that she
doesn't want and she just sticks it on a
shelf in the garage or even throws it
away I'm out ten bucks without any
equivalent gain elsewhere think of all
the millions of Christmas gifts people
have given or received that didn't end
up being used or enjoyed they've all
contributed to a dead weight and loss on
the economy estimated by Walpole to be
around 4.13 billion dollars a year but
you might say those purchases help the
manufacturer and the retailer doesn't
that make up for the loss true but in a
healthy economy businesses make money by
selling products that customers actually
want besides who are you trying to give
a gift to your nephew or Walmart
fortunately deadweight loss is pretty
minimal when it comes to close friends
and relatives because we know them well
enough to make good guesses about what
they'd want but if you're buying for
acquaintances coworkers or extended
family sticking to gift cards might make
them and the economy happier there have
been some movements to take the Commerce
out of Christmas like Buy Nothing day
not coincidentally held on Black Friday
and it is true that many people report
high levels stress or anxiety about
holiday shopping but at the same time
there seems to be a fundamental
connection between Christmas and
spending money that will probably never
go away
just look at the book that people like
to say invented Christmas as we know it
Charles Dickens A Christmas Carol
besides being filled with references to
shops and markets overflowing with goods
for purchase the main characters
principle flaw is that he's a penny
pincher
once Scrooge has his big transformation
and finally understands the true meaning
of Christmas the first thing he does is
throw open the window flagged down a
passing child and tell him to go buy
something go and buy it didn't who
invite good going by if Dickens is right
about Christmas being a celebration of
family and generosity well you can't
throw a party or give to charity without
parting with some mushy lling that
doesn't mean you should Santa yourself
into the poorhouse but humans have an
obvious tradition of connecting through
gift giving so it's okay that for one
month of the year we're willing to make
an investment whose return can't be
recorded in a ledger and that's our two
cents thanks to our patrons for keeping
two cents financially healthy click the
link in the description if you'd like to
support us on patreon what's the most
meaningful gift you've ever received and
how much do you think it cost let us
know in the comments
you